meanwhile here we've completely lost our
minds the left is getting much more
aggressive
this was actually a story from last week
we didn't get a chance to cover it
but it's ramping up again and so i think
it's it's well worth doing
i i was just flying all over uh flew to
georgia flew to florida
flying back and there you know different
airlines are
more serious than others about making
you wear the mask it's got to go over
your nose
they'll come they'll touch you they'll
wake you up to get you to put the mask
up over your nose which seems
counter-productive to me because if they
touch you they're probably more likely
to infect themselves
in any case an airline united airlines
kicked a family off the plane because a
two-year-old would not wear a mask
listen to this woman's story
we just got kicked off the flight
because our
two-year-old would not put on a mask and
we
tried i mean i'm gonna put a video on
and they're sending all of our bags and
adeline's car seat
to new york and we're banned off of
united forever because a two-year-old
would not put on a mask you can actually
see they recorded a little bit of the
interaction on the airplane
listen to the cold
the the cold lack of compassion
from these people just following the
orders from their leftist overlords
so the guys the guy you know the steward
comes up he says you got to get off him
i guess you got to be kidding me
i gave you an opportunity to put the
mask on your tree hole you have to leave
the plane sir
do you guys do this all the time or what
like what if
this is compliance i'm literally holding
over he's like muzzling his daughter
this is
compliance right here i'm sorry sir
she can't force her she's not holding it
and she
needs to muzzle the two-year-old even
though remember that she told us not to
do that like
six months ago well never mind sorry
that's what you got to do
the left is getting much much bolder
much
much bolder than that and we need to i
think we need to go a little further we
need to not just say hey
you do you you choose whatever you want
if it makes you feel better do this do
that
i think we need to be bolder and say no
it's disordered
with few exceptions it is disordered to
wear
masks in public that's what banditos do
that's not what civilized people do
just just like with the mail in voting
it's disordered to have widespread mail
in voting there are limited cases where
it's fine
if you if you're frail or infirm or
you're let's say you're overseas and
maybe then you can have an absentee
ballot you've got to request it
so i'm not saying this one-size-fits-all
ideological solution
but generally speaking the masks are
disordered
the male in voting is disordered we need
to be able to say that we need to have
the courage to not just say do whatever
you want but actually
you should do the things that we are
suggesting you do because
we've used our faculties of reason and
our common sense left is getting a lot
[Music]
bolder
[Music]
you